one of the most legendary investors in
the world bill miller a billionaire has
come out and officially revealed that he
has 50 or so of his personal portfolio
in bitcoin and about 50 of his personal
portfolio in amazon that's right bill
miller has an incredibly heavily
concentrated portfolio he simply looks
for assets that he thinks are durable
that will drive a great return over a
number of years and then he builds
concentrated positions doesn't believe
in diversification for his personal
portfolio and so bill miller if for
those of you that don't know him
literally is a legend he holds the
record for the mutual fund that beat the
s p 500 for 15 consecutive years from
1991 to 2005 every single year he beat
the s p 500 with a mutual fund as the
manager of the leg mason value trust
from the covid induced market low of
march 23rd 2020 through march 31st of
2021 his fund returned 201
versus 78 for the s p 500 and
last year or actually in 2020 bill
miller said amazon had grown to be 83
of his personal portfolio now the reason
why it's interesting is because bill is
famous he bought amazon on the ipo and
then when it crashed after the actual
tech bust
he went in and he bought a material
percent of that business when nobody
wanted it for those of you that don't
know amazon actually fell over ninety
percent nine zero percent and bill
miller stepped in and bought a material
amount of the business at that moment
and has held it pretty much till now and
that is why it's grown to be such a big
portion of his portfolio now with
bitcoin he has done something somewhat
similar he started buying bitcoin in
2014 at 200 and he continued to buy it
until it was at 500 from 200 to 500 bill
miller was buying then he started to buy
again in the spring of 2021 when bitcoin
was about 30k after it had crashed from
66 000 so after a big crash he jumped in
now why exactly was he buying bitcoin
well we have a quote here he says my
reasoning was there are a lot more
people using it now there's a lot more
money going into it in the venture
capital there are a lot of people who
are skeptics who are now at least trying
it out and then his thoughts in terms of
what other people should be doing as he
said if you put one percent of your
portfolio in it for by diversification
even if it goes to zero which i think is
highly improbable but of course possible
you can always afford to lose one
percent so pretty damn cool to see bill
miller an absolute legend somebody who
is a expert in terms of finding
disruptive technologies that compound at
high growth rates obviously showcased
with his amazon investment and now
coming out and saying look i'm into
bitcoin but i'm not just into bitcoin
i've got almost 50
approximately of my personal portfolio
in the asset i think is a pretty big
boom and obviously that set the internet
on fire when people see somebody like
this doing that right john yeah i think
one thing to note here is one bill is a
legend that's very clear i mean he made
200
uh from the bottom of the market to the
top of the market why the s p only
returned like 80 so he clearly knows
what he's doing he's done for a very
very long time um so that cannot be
taken with a grain of salt but he also
he
bitcoin is 50 of his portfolio it's
obviously a lot of monetary value but
it's also in other
stocks such as microstrategy and mining
companies so he's kind of getting
involved in the whole ecosystem of it
it's interesting because when you read
the headlines and it just says bitcoin
is 50 of his portfolio you literally
think that's in cold storage just
sitting on like a usb
so it is interesting to think his notes
on every investor getting exposure to
the asset i think are right on target
one percent you can't really uh you can
afford to lose one percent no one wants
to lose money but you can afford it so i
think he's uh he's right on the ball
with his comments here i mean i mean
that's wild
50
in amazon 50 in bitcoin that's just wild
for uh someone who's worth that much
money a billionaire to be doing
something like that i think a lot of
people would say that's crazy like
people think of the idea of like hey
conviction helps build wealth and then
diversification helps preserve it and he
has just completely followed the
opposite of that right he says these are
the two things i'm highest convicted on
i think they have the most the most
upside the highest chance of success
there are two things that i really
believe in and i'm gonna go all in and
you have to respect that and ultimately
it sounds like um
the way that quote made it sound was he
bought some bitcoin back in whatever
year was 2017 2016 or no 2014 right yeah
2014 to 200 watched it up to 500 and
continue buying and then he started
buying again at 30 000 so it sounds like
he actually bought a smaller portion of
his portfolio and then it continued to
grow and grow and grow and outside other
positions and now ultimately he's left
with two big things which are bitcoin
related assets and amazon and it's two
things that i think a lot of people have
have a high degree of conviction in
right for these assets to continue to
grow over time so to see someone like
this do that and not just be sitting
there in a diversification of stocks
bonds currencies commodities and all
these different assets mutual funds and
all these different things i think it
tells you a lot about him as an investor
right he is willing to go all in on the
things that he believes in and clearly
two of those things are amazon and
bitcoin
the other piece of i think his approach
is that uh he actually holds this stuff
for a really long time right and
ultimately um if you go back and you
actually listen to the interview that he
did there's a two-part interview that
got put on on youtube one is about
stocks and then one is about uh bitcoin
specifically and the segment about
stocks actually was the more interesting
one to me because it showcases how uh
bill thinks he's one of the clearest
investment thinkers that uh that i think
people can learn from um and
what he talks about in there is he says
look uh let's say facebook as an example
facebook had grown in value and that
value uh many people would have said is
oh they're overvalued right the
multiple's too high etc there's
regulatory risk on uh on the horizon
well he's like but yeah that got priced
in because now the multiple is
compressed the stock has come down some
and so given the risk that they face and
given the health of their business it's
actually like a pretty attractive uh
kind of valuation right he goes through
google same thing and he goes through a
couple of these companies then he
talks about amazon which is obviously
something he knows very well and uh he
talked about how amazon is going through
a high period of capital outflow right
they're outlaying a bunch of capital in
terms of uh all their logistics and
transportation building out all the
warehouses and he compares it to places
like uh walmart where he's like look
walking around for 50 60 years doing
this stuff amazon in a short period of
time is gonna have just as much
warehouse space or a competitive amount
of logistical uh um abilities etc and so
the reason why that's all important is
because then what you get is you
basically end up with a scenario that uh
he's explaining okay they're gonna
outlay a bunch of capital today but
that's gonna drive future cash flow
right and that cash flow is gonna be
high cash flow high margin in the future
so owning it today as a business is
super attractive because they're making
investments today that will pay off in
the future now again whether that
happens or not i think is
ultimately up to up to the market and to
performance and all that but it like the
understanding of how a business actually
operates and and the ability to not just
evaluate it in a snapshot a lot of
people look at a business say well how
much cash are they making right now
what's the valuation oh okay this
doesn't make sense because of xyz reason
but he's like no i'm looking at this as
a trajectory of a business or the story
of the business and i'm trying to
understand when are they actually making
high degree of investment what's the
potential payoff of that investment and
how will the the profitability cash flow
etc in the future change again some of
this is like table stakes for uh legacy
wall street stock investors but
there's a lot of people who watch this
show and are kind of new to investing
and i don't think they quite understand
uh you know how to think about uh
valuations today versus how that's going
to move over time and things like
multiples and metrics or multiples and
cash flow and how that can grow or
evolve based on the investments you make
today so as people become more
sophisticated with that stuff i think
that's really where you start to okay
like now you understand investing now
you understand how to select assets now
you understand how to think about
whether something's positive negative um
and which direction it's headed in the
future as well